YouTube is reportedly considering major
changes to its platform that would move
all the videos aimed at kids to the
YouTube kids app the potential move
comes amid calls for YouTube to better
protect young viewers from accessing
objectionable content and there is also
of course an ongoing debate about how
the platform should police extremist
content solving controversy over
YouTube's decision to D monetize
conservative commentator Steve Crowder
over allegations of bullying here to
discuss both of these issues is host of
the david pakman show david pakman
himself his program also was demonetised
in the wake of changes to youtube back
when was that david that that happened
that was April 2017 yeah so a little
while ago so David thanks so much for
being with us we really appreciate it
thank you so just give us a little bit
of your view of how YouTube should be
handling the proliferation of extremist
content on the platform
well listen there's sort of two
standards that I think we need to apply
here there's one of monetization and
there's other of content being allowed
on the platform and I think that that's
being lost in a lot of the conversations
that start to talk about things like
free speech and censorship it's really
important to understand that there's no
sort of inherent right to monetization
never mind to publish content on YouTube
my personal view is I want as much
speech as possible and short of illegal
content that content should be allowed
on the platform the question of whether
advertisers should be forced to or
expect it to advertise on content they
or their customers might find
objectionable though is a different one
and monetization is a different sort of
standard than the content itself being
allowed yeah well they don't have a
right to add roles right that's exactly
right and a lot of the questions around
this are focused on monetization when
the arguments being made seem to apply
more to whether the content itself
should be allowed and it's really
important to distinguish what it is that
we're talking about yeah David another
thing I've seen the criticism of is okay
maybe he doesn't maybe he doesn't
deserve ads on his platform steven
crowder but it's the haphazard way in
which these changes and these things go
about I heard you talk a little bit
about this on the Joe Rogan podcast just
outlined
you think a comprehensive solution that
YouTube might be able to take because
you set as you outlined yourself one day
you just woke up and there were
significant changes to your own channel
yeah I mean it's important to understand
that the idea of someone deserves
monetization is an extraordinarily
strange argument to make when we're
talking about a company Google and
YouTube that has Terms of Service and
should be allowed to apply them I think
my concern is the uneven application of
some of these policies and it seems to
often be very much directed by what
creates a public outcry or discussion in
the media when there is tons of content
just by virtue of how many hours of
stuff is uploaded to YouTube every
minute
there's tons of content that is arguably
not legal content and or certainly not
brand safe that never even makes any
headlines because nobody's watching it
and so my concern is is the policy being
applied evenly and fairly of course
YouTube is allowed to have Terms of
Service and enforce them assuming they
don't violate non-discrimination laws or
whatever else may be sort of the legal
status quo but we've got to apply it
equally across the board we have a
number of recent incidents where people
who took or attempted to take violent
actions had a history of basically
YouTube radicalization there's been a
lot of written about this recently I
mean to me the problem with YouTube
seems sort of more fundamental than
we're gonna block this person we're
going to demonetised that person which
is that the algorithm itself at least up
to this point has promoted this kind of
path to extremism well I think it's
interesting what you what you mentioned
because all of these platforms are
fundamentally designed to increase watch
time on the basis of you watched video a
what videos BC and D can the algorithm
show you that are most likely to keep
you watching as long as possible and in
the same way that a lot of people we've
now learned have been radicalized by
these echo chambers that are created I
also am hearing from viewers who have
been deprogrammed from radical
right-wing thinking because of that same
algorithm where they went from
right-wing extremist content to someone
who's debating right-wing extremist
content
to something like me so I think there's
examples of all of this stuff but
there's no question that the algorithm
is amoral in the sense that all it wants
to do is keep you watching or consuming
content for as long as possible that's
an excellent point David but the reason
that we have you is because you're a
progressive YouTube star and I would
love your take on the current state of
the Democratic primary particularly what
we're dealing with here in Washington
which is the fallout from Joe Biden's
comments on comparing in waxing
nostalgic for working with
segregationist
while he was in Congress is how is it
that progressives are gonna have to
reconcile themselves if Joe Biden will
become the nominee if we're seventeen
months out and he's already doing stuff
like this well there's a couple
different things there one there's not
that much reconciliation to do right now
right now it's which candidate most
aligns with your values and who is
presenting policy positions that are
most in line with what you want to see
and that's that's who you support I mean
we haven't even had the first debate
we're already seeing that Joe Biden has
been pretty significantly trailing off
from I think he spiked to around 42% in
the polls after he announced he was
running he's down almost 10 points now
and it's been mostly Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren that have been sort of
picking up on those declines from Joe
Biden so I think that in the end most
progressives would agree that basically
every option right now
running on the Democratic side would be
a better alternative to Donald Trump but
that's a conversation for at least we've
after we've had a couple debates right
now it's support who you most believe in
it's interesting that you say that
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders are
picking up that support from Joe Biden
I've certainly seen that with war and
she seems to be rising in the polls
pulling in a second and some but what's
what are you seeing in terms of Bernie
Sanders that would justify that comment
well so in the last five or so days
Bernie Sanders has declined a little bit
in the polls and Elizabeth Warren has
gained but if you go back to the sort of
four weeks following Joe Biden's
original announcement you can actually
track almost every point that Joe Biden
lost was picked up by Bernie Sanders
like 80 percent with the other 20% going
to other candidates so I think just if
you look at you know
RealClearPolitics polling average you'll
see that Bernie Sanders gain mirror Joe
Biden's decline up until about five or
seven days ago at which point it's been
Elizabeth Warren that's been gaining so
a tactical question for you David
something I've been asking a lot of the
progresses on this show which is that
Elizabeth Warren has brand herself she
says I'm a capitalist but I'm for an
economic patriotism plan much of the
same proposals that would come in
practice with the Bernie Sanders however
crystal and I were actually at that
rally what Bernie Sanders embraced the
Democratic Socialist label saying no
matter what they do they're gonna call
you a socialist and I am a Democratic
Socialist was it tactically was it
tactically better for Elizabeth Warren
to call herself an economic patriot wrap
herself in language familiar to the
normal American who isn't may be afraid
of socialism than it was for Bernie
Sanders to embrace the socialist label
I'm less sure about whether what
Elizabeth Warren did was correct then I
am sure that what Bernie Sanders is
doing is counterproductive and I've been
talking about this on my program I mean
I voted for Bernie in the 2016 primary
and even in 2015 I was saying his
policies are not socialist policies
they're socially Democratic policies in
the line of the Nordic economies and it
is counterproductive particularly when
socialist is a smear that is very well
used by many on the right in the United
States there's no reason to be doing
this sort of self-inflicted damage and I
understand the argument if either way
they're going to call a socialist why
not embrace the label the reason not to
embrace of embrace the label is that
social democracy is capitalism it's well
regulated capitalism not socialism and I
do think that it's just a strategic and
tactical mistake I mean that is a funny
thing is that he he is not a socialist
he I mean here's the thing he may be a
socialist and Elizabeth Warren is a
capitalist but on policy if they've come
very very close I mean Elizabeth
Warren's approach is to work a little
bit more within the structure and tweak
it whereas Bernie's approach is to
change that structure but even if they
in the 70s one came from a capitalist
side and one came from an actual
socialist side their platform and policy
today is social democracy and I think
that's how it should be branded well in
its mainstream
I mean Bernie Sanders platform within
the Democratic Party is at this point
fairly mainstream I think my take is a
little bit different I think it'd be
very hard for him to try to embrace a
different label at this point when he
has like 40 years of calling himself
Democratic Socialist so I think probably
the calculus is this is who you are this
is what you've been calling yourself
let's try to make it more comfortable
for people and situate it within an
American context that maybe that maybe
it's just not accurate and I think that
at a certain point we should be calling
things what they are and single-payer
health care and using taxation of
financial transactions that had no value
to the economy to make sure that nobody
is left behind at the bottom that's
social democracy that's Sweden Norway
Denmark etc and I think we should just
call things what they are yeah it's an
interesting I think this is this is
really one of the core fights that
what's gonna come down to if there is an
alternative to Joe Biden in the
Democratic primary but I'm also
intrigued by I mean the rise of Pete
Budaj as kind of a alternative to Joe
Biden for much of the neoliberal elite
what is it that you think what is it
about him that that progressives have
have been very suspect of him despite so
much of this embrace from the media some
progressives have been suspect of him
some of not I mean I think that what P
Buddha judge has has going for him is
that he is extremely articulate in
presenting what are in practice very
similar views to Joe Biden so whereas
Joe Biden has been relatively gaffe
prone and and maybe putting the least
favorable spin on some of his ideas
Buddha judge is sort of the opposite but
it's coming at the expense of depth
because when I see people judge speak
I'm I'm under some interpreting that a
lot of the policies are similar to those
of Joe Biden but they are sort of
lacking in detail and ultimately when
the debates actually start that may be
something that hurts him I want to ask
you another YouTube question kind of a
different vein is the left losing on
YouTube it depends what you mean by
losing I mean there have been studies
done that compare this the total
audience size of the left versus right
on YouTube and there have been studies
that compare the number of left wing
versus right wing channels on YouTube
and
depending on how you measure it you get
a sort of different answer I think that
the most important thing is without
getting into the nitty-gritty of the
numbers corporate media presents mostly
a corporatist sensationalist point of
view so even whether you're talking
about CNN or MSNBC that MSNBC
editorially takes more of a center-left
position the primary sort of filter is
ratings and profit and just having an
alternative to that on YouTube is a
really great thing for the left even if
they are five percent behind or five
percent ahead of the right on YouTube I
actually don't know the answer as to who
is winning because who is winning
depends on what it is that you're
measuring but there's no question that
the big YouTube channels have presented
really valuable alternative to the sort
of centrist corporatist line that we get
on most corporate media and then of
course you have Fox News which is a
different approach altogether and and I
think that comment applies to the right
as well it's the YouTube perspective
presented by the right is not centrist
or corporatist you know from what I've
seen it's a more reactionary version of
the right and do you think that's the
direction that the Republican Party will
ultimately head in well we've seen if
you go to the 2010 Tea Party movement as
a movement it basically no longer exists
because some elements of it just
dissolved and some elements of it were
integrated into the broader Republican
Party and now the Republican Party is
slightly more Tea Party esque than it
was before 2010 and in the same way I
think you've seen some of that extreme
conspiracy right be integrated from the
YouTube sphere and from alternative
media and so sometimes conspiracy
theories make it onto Fox News they have
sort of bled over into that more
corporate right-wing media narrative I
aggressively concerning it'll be up to
the people that are part of that
movement to decide whether those are
voices that they want to be heard within
mainstream conservatism one thing I do
find though interesting David and I
procure this for your perspective on
this you went on the Joe Rogan podcast
you you've engaged with guys
like Dave Rubin I mean they are
frequently smeared in the New York Times
and others as gateways to the alt-right
do you think that that is a fair thing
to say because as you said as for as
many people who may have been
radicalized on YouTube there may at me
as many people who have been de
radicalized on YouTube yeah I think more
people have been radicalized than D
radicalized it's anecdotal but at least
from from the calls that I get it seems
that there's more there are many ways
into being rattled radicalized on
YouTube and it seems that the ways out
are fewer and further between but I
think there's no question that yeah my
approach has always been I don't want
unchallenged radical ideas on my program
if I interview someone who is an
extremist right-wing or like white
nationalist Richard Spencer who is very
tied in with the alt-right for example
I'm not going to provide a platform for
his ideas to be stated unopposed I will
only take on those interviews if number
one I believe that the ideas are
prominent enough that they're worth
challenging but number two that I'm the
right person to challenge them that's my
approach and I think you're alluding to
some people that have a different
approach what was that experience like
on the Rogan podcast that's like he gets
such an insane audience what does that
been like for you it's been great in
terms of people learning about my
program and I've heard from many sort of
center-right people who say I don't
really agree with a lot of your
conclusions but I appreciate you sort of
being upfront and how you reach them and
that's a better way to engage on the
ideas rather than add homonyms and bad
faith arguments so I mean once you get
there it's just a two-hour conversation
with another guy in a room and it's sort
of very informal and casual then you
leave and you realize that he has this
audience of millions and everything you
said is being analyzed but it was a
great experience well thank you so much
for joining us David I had to get you on
the show after we heard you there
really interesting perspective one of
the most
[Laughter]
David thank you a lot more rising after
those
[Music]